[Music]
when out do a mom who was also the
people's princess Diana what happened 56
years old watching her youngest son
Harry marry the love of his life Kelsey
is back with us from London and many
people have been comparing Megan to
Diana from the start Kelsey yeah Nancy
so we couldn't help but wonder what
Diana would have thought about her
soon-to-be daughter-in-law
I think Diana would be delighted I think
she'd be thrilled that he's clearly so
happy she can handle the media attention
she seems really ready to get to work to
be a royal yeah he's found his match
Harry and William adored their mother
Diana's influence reached halfway across
the world to Los Angeles where a young
Megan seemed to be very moved by Diana's
death when she was a teenager she was
affected by the funeral as many people
were and she and her friends gathered
together toys and games and gave them to
children who are less fortunate kind of
signaling time is passing the late
Princess of Wales put her heart into
helping others through her charity work
before Megan even met Harry she was a UN
Ambassador for women trying to make her
own mark in bettering people's lives I
think he probably does see quite a bit
of his mother in in Megan's certainly
that campaigning spirit and that desire
to you know shine the spotlight on the
vulnerable and the needy William was
only 15 and Harry 12 when they lost
their mother I find it interesting that
Dinah died at 36 Megan comes into the
royal family aged 36 and in a curious
psychic kind of way picks up the royal
of the Dinah mantle both her son's have
memorialized their mother through the
engagement rings they chose for their
fiance's Kate's massive sapphire and
diamond ring was the very same one his
father Prince Charles gave Diana Harry
created Megan's ring with a special
remembrance to Diana the little diamonds
either side are for my mother's juried
collection to make sure what she's with
us on this crazy journey together it's
beautiful and he designed it it's
incredible
yeah yeah you make sure it stays on my
finger
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]